we're welcoming Donald Trump to
Washington DC we're letting him know
that we've legalized here and that we
don't want our rights taken away we're
trying to reach out to the Trump
supporters we're trying to reach out to
the biker gangs that are coming to town
we've spoken with them we're gonna be
giving marijuana to everybody the one
place in town where you found Trump
supporters and people who are opposed to
Trump doing something together might end
up being waiting in line for marijuana
[Music]
we're rolling thousands of marijuana
joints to give away at Donald Trump's
inauguration it's an opportunity to keep
the issue of marijuana reform on the
agenda marijuana one big on election
night we had eight out of nine state
initiatives passed we still see a
federal government that's completely out
of touch while I really like some of the
things Donald Trump has said about the
drug war and about marijuana in the past
the appointment of senator sessions was
a total alarm bell for us this drug is
dangerous you cannot play with it it's
not funny it's not something to laugh
about
and and trying to send that message with
clarity that good people don't smoke
marijuana we're afraid that the progress
we've made to legalize marijuana here in
the nation's capital
legalizing with 70% of the vote we're
afraid that's gonna be taken away
[Music]
may be safe to say because I don't want
the protesters kick my ass but my mother
used to work at the Trump Taj Mahal for
Donald Trump and I am a speak Trump and
I've been a fan since the 90s I haven't
drunk in over 15 years that stuff is
dangerous
cannabis however is not so I don't think
he's got to mess up with the freedoms we
already got legalized marijuana they
should got out I wish I was freaking you
know 35 years younger I'm 53 years old I
would have I would have been across the
street smoking up a storm
I'm a nine-year-old daughter that
suffers from epilepsy and I'm happy to
say nine months later most 5060 seizures
that she was having today have been
reduced to 91% seizure free I believe
Jeff Sessions needs education I don't
really want to attack him I think when
you're educated to make uneducated
comments well I sure hope that Trump
ends up supporting the legalization of
marijuana I'm from Colorado and over in
Colorado marijuana is legal and things
are going just finally it's absolutely
completely normal
[Applause]
this is your day this is your
celebration everyone is listening to you
now
you came by the tens of millions
[Music]
thank you god bless you
thank you
god bless america
[Music]